325 مليون دولار ترث في الميناء منذ اشهر
انه احد اليخوت الفارهه التي تعود ملكيتها
لاولي غارشين روس العديد من املاك واصول
الطبقه الاوليغارشيه في روسيا والتي فرض
عليها الغرب عقوبات اقتصاديه اثر الحرب
على اوكرانيا تم تجميدها يحتفظ بها البنك
المركزي الروسي في حسابات المصرفيه
الاجنبيه لكن المبدعين الفيدراليين
يحاولون مصادره الممتلكات والاموال
الروسيه عوضا عن التجميد فقط ما يسمح
بتحويلها الى الحكومه للتصرف بها ان القله
الحاكمه تنقل الاصول من ملكيتها المباشره
وسيطرتها الى صناديق الاستئنانيه الى
افراد الاسره والشركاء او الى اسهم في
طبقات من الشركات في ولايات قضائيه
بعد ان هدمت المدافع الروسيه الابنيه
والبنيه التحتيه اموال روسيه قد تكون حجر
الاساس لاعاده الحياه لاوكرانيا فمذكرات
الاستدعاء التي تصدرها المحاكم الفيدراليه
لاختراق الطبقات المعقده والتي تخفي
ممتلكات الاوليغارشيه هي جزء من الجهود
الغربيه لاجبار روسيا على الانسحاب من
اوكرانيا وايجاد مصادر تمويل لكيف واعاده
اعمار ما دمرته الحرب الروسيه في البلاد
خطط تبدو الحل المرجوه لخفض اعباء
اوكرانيا الاقتصاديه الا ان العصي في عجله
هذه العمليه لا تقتصر على صعوبه ايجاد
المقتنيات من يخوتا ومجوهرات وعقارات في
الانتقال من التجميد الى المصادره ليس
بتلك السلاسه القانون الامريكي يمنح سلطه
محدوده لمصادره الاصول المجمده ويتعين على
الكونغرس تمرير قانون جديد
موقع الاصول قد يتطلب سنوات من التحقيق
دمار يستغرق اشهر تسعه قد يحتاج اجيال
لتغطيه الضرر المديل الذي لحق بالبنيه
التحتيه والمنازل والمعامل وليس من الواضح
ما اذا كانت جميع الاوراق الماليه وغيرها
من المقتنيات ستكون كافيه لتغطيه التكلفه
الدمار الى عمر العربيه